so we've heard a lot of talks about new
functionality there's no new
functionality here this is a complete
retooling of existing functionality so
it's not on Stephens word cloud of new
functions I'm going to give a brief
overview about elementary functions
transcendental functions how they
computed in high precision I try and
give you some examples and I'll outline
some new work to substantially speed up
the evaluation of these functions so the
first thing I want to show you is a
comparison this is not by me this is by
a team that develops the mpf are
packaged so basically they've taken a
bunch of so they've taken a bunch of
different packages don't worry too much
about the timing from Mathematica here
because this is Mathematica version 6
which is from july two thousand seven
actually mathematically is comparable to
the best of these systems here mpfr the
main points i want to point out our all
of these libraries use for the basic
arithmetic this this new multiple
position library for the core arithmetic
that's some multiplication division
addition subtraction and you see that
that doesn't have any support for
elementary functions so all of these
other packages all of these special
purpose packages implement their own
version and my benchmark has always been
mpfr which is a by a group of inner ear
which is an extension to the canoe
multiple position library and it's part
of GCC actually used by GCC the gnu
compiler to compute high precision
approximations when actually compiling
stuff and mathematically is actually
comparable with with mpfr what i also
like to point out that if there's this
new kid on the block here ARB this new
ARB library and the timings involved
here are the fastest system and what you
can see is this art library suddenly has
become four times faster than the new
mpf our library so i'm going to discuss
the ideas in this ARB library and i'm
going to discuss how they've been
incorporated into mathematica
okay so just a very quick example of the
sort of thing I'm talking about
mathematik it provides two types of
arithmetic one is fixed precision here I
fixed the precision at 20 digits and
I've computed the cosine of some small
value if I then go and use the inversion
formula this is equivalent to the sine
function then I get a complete loss of
precision in fixed position when the
argument here is quite small this is 10
to the minus 30 and this is a typical
behavior of using a fixed number of
digits so in mathematical we have an
alternative model called significance
arithmetic which locally models the
conditioning of the function and hear
what you see is you don't get a fixed
number of digits but you get a growing
number of digits depending on the
conditioning of the function at this
argument and when you invert this funk
this this quantity to get the equivalent
of the sine function you get a
completely accurate answer ok so this is
the kind of the default arithmetic that
we use in Mathematica in something like
ND solve will switch this arithmetic off
and we'll use this fixed position
arithmetic and we'll use local error
estimation from a differential equation
solver or something like that to control
the error instead so applications of
arbitrary precision in Mathematica well
they're everywhere I mean I've listed
some but they're really really
everywhere I mean they used in all parts
for Eve even even regions and stuff
here's one example excuse me that uses
reduced produces these solutions to x
log equations these root objects
transcendental root objects and here i
can take numerical approximations for
these things and get arbitrary
approximations and that actually is
computing these elementary functions to
high precision so what are arbitrary
appreciated numbers were essentially
they're concatenations of integers an
arbitrary array of integers each of
these digits in here is a machine
integer so it's an array of machine
integers and each of these block of
digits represents either nine or
nineteen approximately on a 32 or 64-bit
machine but basically at the heart of
every arbitrary position number is an
array of integers and that array of into
is growing and representing the number
of digits that you have and it can be
arbitrarily little so as I said all of
the libraries that I showed on the first
slide use this new multi-purpose Newton
library when i first started every
single library would use its own ad hoc
method ok this is good for us because it
means if we also use this library which
we do now for at least a decade we can
compare our implementation and our
algorithms to other other systems and we
can see how good they are because we're
all using the same core underlying
fundamentals so it kind of levels the
playing field everybody so what I'm
specifically going to talk about here is
computing trig functions so there are
three components to computing a trig
function the first is a range reduction
that's to bring the argument within a
range in which the approximation is
going to converge the second one is
called argument reduction once you have
it in a range where the series is going
to converge you're going to make it even
smaller to try and accelerate the
convergence of the series and the third
one is the actual evaluation now the
actual evaluation is different depending
on if you're using machine precision you
might use a corded or a minimax
approximation in arbitrary precision we
use a Taylor series but even evaluating
the Taylor series an arbitrary precision
can involve different methods have been
on how much precision we're using so
there's the basic summation algorithm
which is basically going including
computing products and summing them up
there's something called rectangular
splitting which which I'll outline a
little bit later and something called
binary splitting which is used for
extremely high precision that's outside
the scope of this talk I'm not going to
cover that today so the first thing to
do you have sine or X for some number or
something the first thing to do is to
bring in a range in which the series is
going to converge and you do that by
subtracting off multiples of PI over 2
or of log of 2 okay to reduce the
magnitude of this argument and here are
a few different examples of different
functions and that means that we have to
compute PI or log
two or something like that too high
precision and we have very good
algorithms for doing that once we've
done that we have something like X is
less than 10 k x 2 x is less than 1 it
might be naught point nine or not point
eight or something it's the serious is
going to converge quite slowly so what
we ideally want is something quite small
okay like 10 to the minus 10 or 10 to
the minus 20 in which case the series is
going to converge much much more quickly
so then we can use functional relations
to do that and here are a couple of them
here's one for X okay this says if I
want to evaluate the exponential
function at some argument I can actually
evaluate half of that argument go and do
that and then just square it at the end
okay so i can do this like 10 times or
something like that i can reduce it by a
by 2 10 times so it's now 2 to the minus
10 and then I just square the result 10
times and I get back the original input
but the actual computation that's gone
on in here is is much much more
efficient and some functions are
computed together like sign is related
to cause so these two functions are
computed together and scientists is
related to Kosh so the new idea in is
art library why it's so fast is quite
interesting it's it uses a lookup table
okay so it doesn't do this functional
relationship because it here in order to
make a number smaller I had to do a
squaring I had to divide by two go and
compute the series and then square the
result okay squaring the result
multiplication in high position is
expensive so what if I could reduce the
argument somehow without having to pay
that cost and that's what this library
does so basically it sets up these
tables now if I want to knock out say
the first 16 bits make something to to
the minus 16 then I need a lookup table
that's two to the 16 entries that's
quite a lot quite a lot of storage but I
don't have to do that I can do to 8-bit
tables okay and I can use a formula to
to concatenate those together in two
8-bit tables is a lot lot smaller
than one 16-bit table but it still
knocks out 16 bits so here's an example
to show you what's going on this is my
number okay my arbitrary position number
I'm going to take the first eight bits
okay and I'm just going to take them
away and put zeros there and then i'm
going to call whatever was in here a
rational number p1 over q1 okay it's
just a rational number then I'm going to
take the next eight bits knock them out
just put them 20 and i'll call whatever
this purple bit here is p2 over q2 it's
another rational number okay now I've
got a number that's got 16 leading zeros
ok it's 2 to the minus 16 my series
approximation of that number is going to
be very very fast ok that's my X of X 2
here can compute that really quickly but
I've taken bits out here so what I've
computed here is not the same as what I
had here i have to add back in this and
this and i have to multiply the 3 things
together ok but this is exponential of a
rational number and i just get it from a
lookup table and this is exponential of
a different rationale rational number
and i just get that from another lookup
table ok so these kinds of ideas also
using hardware but in hardware you have
restrictions with the size of the die
and everything I mean it'sit's CPUs are
expensive to kind of construct the point
is here that I can build these look-up
tables and I can build them up lazily I
can just say have two 8-bit look-up
tables fill them up as you need to so
each time I go and go through the
exponential function I fill out one new
entry in each of these two tables and
the nice thing is for something like
indie solve where I'm evaluating cosines
or signs over and over again with very
similar bit sequences in the beginning
because they're all quite near to each
other numbers I can just go and get all
of these leading bits from these look-up
tables ok recycle them over and over
again instead of having to use those
formula for reducing the arguments and
paying the cost of the work to bring the
number down in size each time so if I
restructure the code correct
then really there's only four series
that I have to evaluate okay arc tan and
arc tan CH which are pretty similar
except for the alternating sine and sine
and sine okay where this has a factorial
in the denominator and these are just
the odd numbers okay so these are the
only series that have to actually worry
about evaluating so once I've got part
of miami's are out from the lookup table
I I still have to go and compute this
this series now for the exponential
functions I I can use some kind of
symmetries so here the exponential
function involves all powers but if I
compute the series for sine CH which is
just the odd powers then I can use the
inversion formula to get the cosine CH
and I can just add the two together so
here I've only valuated a series with
half the number of terms and just by
doing a square root and ask where I've
effectively got the exponential so I've
effectively cut the work in half here
because this series is like half as
expensive to evaluate as this series
okay and a similar kind of idea for the
logarithm it's a pretty neat trick using
this identity here we have a
relationship between the logarithm and
the arctangent and here I vasu sort of
the logarithm near one but and I can use
this series of the art tange which is
only evolving odd powers okay so these
are kind of tricks to to kind of reduce
the size and number of terms that you
need to evaluate but at the end of the
day I still need to evaluate some series
okay so here it is a top level just a
top level implementation too so the sort
of thing you do basically take each new
term multiplied it and divide multiply
and divide multiply divide over and over
and over in a loop okay and if I use
compare this kind of top level
implementation with what I have
internally it's more than 100 times
slower so i'll give you an indication of
why why that is what's happening is I
have a lot of data structures with a
very very short lifespan okay i'm
multiplying some product i'm adding it
in
I'm creating something for the result
then I'm throwing it away i'm adding in
something else i'm creating allocating
memory throwing away and all of the
arithmetic that i'm doing is general
arithmetic for floating point numbers it
has to check for overflows it has to
normalize numbers it has to check for
changes in position and all of that is
quite expensive when I'm evaluating the
series I know that I'm working in a
really specific range all the numbers
are smaller than one the exponent is
bounded nothing is ever going to
overflow so the essential is idea is to
just make a big memory block one big
memory block and just put all of those
numbers in this big memory block and do
all of the arithmetic in one memory
block and just shift pointers around
doing the arithmetic and that's why this
is so much faster than actually writing
in Mathematica because there's no data
structures there's no overhead from
repeated allocation and free you're not
going through these generic routines to
do floating-point arithmetic you're just
really working at the word level and the
inside of the of the floating point
numbers and the second trick is that
even though these are scalar divisions
here divisions are more expensive than
multiplications okay if I take late
let's take like the first five terms
okay and compute the least common
multiple as this number here and the
next five terms and compute the least
common multiple then i can rewrite this
which evolves all these divisions are
something like this where these are now
multiplications and only every five
terms do i do it a division right so now
i'm using primitives from the new
multiple precision library these fused
add multiply which is the core of
multiplication they're all implemented a
highly optimizing assembler so I've
transformed my problem into something
which the lie be can do really fast okay
now the second thing that we didn't have
before is another way to more
efficiently evaluate the series
something
all direct rectangular splitting so it
works like this you build up a table of
powers okay so I want to compute a
Taylor series with 16 terms I build up a
table of powers that go up to the square
root the number the number of powers
here is four powers which is the square
root of a number of terms in the series
and I rearranged my Taylor series to use
these tables of powers over and over and
over again and i just multiply the
nested fashion by some power and if you
expand all this out then you'll get like
the Taylor series if you call expand on
this you'll get the Taylor series the
first 16 terms of the Taylor series
right but look it's in that
implementation I showed you the basic
evaluation I had to do one squaring and
15 multiplications to do it here I've
done three squaring than five
multiplications all right so you can see
that the complexity of this procedure is
much much lower than the complexity of
doing in standard way but there's a
problem because this and this is exactly
how r the r bleib it does it does it
using this rectangular splitting not not
using the basic summation but we had
something when the basic summation
that's not here and that is when you're
computing the tail end of the Taylor
series those terms at the tail end are
much much smaller than the terms at the
beaning their high up higher order
powers and you can see them here this X
to the 8th is much smaller than x
squared because we're talking about
something that has like all these
leading zeros okay and in the ARB lie be
all of these terms all computed to the
same precision irrespective of whether
they occur at the end of the series or
at the beginning of the series so when I
was preparing this talk last month what
I thought was it will be nice if i could
put what we have this sliding precision
variable precision from the basic method
into this algorithm for rectangular
splitting and i'm pleased to say that i
didn't think it was going to be possible
but i have managed to do it it's never
been done before so this is the first
time I from Attica and it works like
this these terms
they get successively clearer are
computed with successively lower
precision okay and because they're done
in a memory block that's just shifting
pointers I'm using less and less digits
as they go along ok so this hardly any
overhead to do that right so I start
from the end i compute all these terms
and this multiplication and they're all
done using much lower precision then I
get to the second row I raise the
precision a little bit compute this and
add it to this raise the precision a bit
more compute this and added to this and
then finally do this with a full width
with the full precision so now let's
look at this is like the Olympics and I
guess it's like presidential elections I
need some sporting an allergy or
something like that right to connect
with people so this is like this is like
100 digits it's like the sprint final
okay and this is like you know 10,000
meters or something like that mpfr which
is the you know the most commonly used
multiple position like me that's the one
in blue mathematica 10.3 is green it's
not it's not too bad I mean it gives
gives mpfr a good run for its money even
though mpfr has this rectangular
splitting our of them and we didn't the
fact that we use the sliding precision
for the basic for an inferior algorithm
but evaluated more Intel intelligently
we're fairly competitive and then around
this region around a thousand digits or
so we switched to a different method so
you can see there's a little bit of
awkwardness here this is this ARB
library okay which is Sir like Usain
Bolt comes along young guy and suddenly
blows away the competition here but it's
not very good at long distances so when
you get to like a thousand digits or
something kind of fades away a little
bit and then just use this the other the
other methods okay and this is the new
implementation in the development
version of Mathematica what you can see
is its jack when I bear this go if I
thought this is
just remarkably smooth I mean it's one
algorithm that's adapting through the
precision okay it's adapting itself it's
making like in a square rectangular way
building up these tables in a nice
smooth dynamic way and you don't get any
of the behavior that you get with any of
the other systems it's not switching
between hard-coded values of switching
between different alphabets that just
smoothly adjust itself and I always
thought it was only really useful for
like a around a thousand two thousand
three thousand digits now we use it all
the way down I've completely thrown away
the old code this completely replaces it
even at like 20 digits or something like
that and it's fast or even at like 30 or
40,000 digits so it's right from the
very low end 20 digits all the way up to
40,000 digits and it's the fastest of
any system anywhere this is on a
logarithmic scale so it kind of tends to
compress the difference between the
systems so what I did was a performance
profile too so you can see this is how
many times slower the other systems are
for a bunch of different functions and
this is the ARB library so we're kind of
in the low precision range may only
fifty percent faster than a factor of
two factor of three we're about a factor
of five or six Laster than the mpf are
and in this the mpf our algorithm for
our town isn't very good it doesn't use
a stainless it uses some kind of
iterative method and it's more than like
20 20 times slower in this particular
range but the important thing is that
that then it's that it's very fast and
it's very fast for a very wide range of
precision and that means that you can do
a lot more computations and a lot more
computations in smaller precision than
you could before I mean it's like three
or four or five times fast is the
difference between waiting a day or
waiting a few hours for something to
compute and the other thing is because
of this lookup table type of mechanism
is very well suited to something like ND
solve or find root or find minimum where
you're doing very similar car
of trig function evaluations over and
over and over again it's going to make
use of these look-up tables and and
recycle those values so I tried to give
you an overview of the computational
issues there's been a substantial code
infrastructure overhaul to try and make
this jump John was talking about 250
commits or something for the get link
this is like a thousand something like
that there's a new internal
functionality we do like range reduction
also at the word word level the new
thing is to use these argument reduction
cash look-up tables like the ARB library
does we use this coefficient rescaling
method to reduce the number of divisions
like the arbor library does and we use
rectangular splitting like the ARB
library does but in an adaptive
precision fashion which is which is
which is new it's competitive with the
state of the art for low precision up to
us a 200 250 digits there is a little
bit of interpreted overhead from using
Mathematica but use inside something
like a numerical function or something
like that for Indies or whatever that
kind of dies away but it's the most
efficient implementation anywhere in any
system from around 250 to 30,000 digits
it's only been like a month I've got
this working so I'm still fine-tuning
like the cash table sizes and how many
of them to use at what precision and
that kind of stuff and I'm still looking
at bringing down this very very low you
know bring it bringing down the lower
precision 20 30 40 50 digits just to
reduce a little bit of overhead there as
well and the other nice thing is that
I've completely eliminated all of the
old code so this now completely
supersedes or all of the code that we've
had before